>>Presenter: Hi everyone.
Alright, what a crowd, this is awesome.
I’m Winnie Lam and it’s my pleasure to host
our guest, Premal Shah who is the president
of Kiva, to Google today.
And Gary Briggs is from Google and he’s gonna
be hosting the fireside chat but I guess we’re
kind of missing the fire.
I mean, the fire’s in them.
[Laughter]
>>Presenter: Anyway, let me tell you about
Premal.
So, Premal is the president of Kiva.
He first dreamed of internet microfinance
back in 2004 when he was working at PayPal.
And so, at that time, he took a three month
leave and developed the internet microfinance
concept in India.
Well, he came back, didn’t go back to PayPal
and he came back, quit his job at PayPal and
launched Kiva thereafter.
And today Kiva raises over a million dollars
every single week to help the working poor
in 60 countries, very impressive.
For Premal’s accomplishments as a social
entrepreneur, he was named a young global
leader by World Economic Forum and selected
to Fortune Magazine’s top 40 under 40 in
2009.
Now let me tell you interesting things about
Premal.
[Laughter]
>>Presenter: So, Premal has been known to
do the worm dance in weddings.
So, maybe, if we’re lucky we can, okay, during
the Q and A one of you have gotta ask him
to do a demo.
Okay, I didn’t tell you about this beforehand,
sorry.
[Laughter]
>>Presenter: Anyway, so Gary is doing the
chat with Premal today and most recently Gary
is the, Google’s Vice President of Consumer
Marketing.
And one of Gary’s roles prior to coming to
Google was at PayPal where he headed up the
global marketing team.
And, in fact, it was in the hallways where
Premal and Gary first talked about Kiva.
So, without further ado, please help me give
a really warm welcome to Premal Shah and Gary
Briggs.
[Applause]
>>Gary Briggs: Hi everybody.
I’ll just go through, what we’ll do is I’ll
ask Premal a series of questions over the
next kind of 40 minutes or so and then we’ll
take questions at the end.
So, hopefully we’ll licit some discussion
at the end.
I also know Premal a little bit, as Winnie
was saying, and he’s a pretty humble guy
so it was exactly the reaction I expected
from you when she started talking about your
background, you’re like looking down, right?
[Laughter]
>>Gary Briggs: Shucks!
So, Winnie told a little bit about the story
of how you got started but I do remember there
was a lot of discussion about the beginnings
of microfinance in the hallways and then you
just, you just had this fire about getting
started.
So talk about the early bid of getting started.
>>Premal Shah: Sure, sure.
Well, thanks everyone for making the time
in the middle of your day to come here.
And, you know, one thing I wanted to talk
about is something I’m sure everyone in the
room and everyone who is kind of watching
feels which is, at one point in your life
you may have had an experience with poverty.
And, for me, I was raised in a middle class
family in Minnesota, in the suburbs of Minnesota.
And when I was 5 years old my parents brought
me back to India for the first time.
And, you know, there is a, there is a memory,
for me, that really affected me which was
I was walking through a village, there’s
this town Dabhoi which is in Gujarat, the
state of Gujarat.
And it’s where my father was raised and it
was rainy season and the streets were pretty
muddy and we were in a market.
And I was holding on to my mom’s hand and
my mom gave me a one paise coin to hold onto
and we were walking through and it was a little
muddy and I dropped the one paise coin in
the mud and my mom pulled me away saying,
“Oh, it’s dirty.” And within seconds, a
woman who was older than my mom, in a ragged
sari,uh, walked over, leaned over very slowly,
picked up the coin from that mud and then
pointed, you know, looked up at the sky and
thanked God for finding this one paise coin.
And, you know, as a 5 year old, you’ve witnessed
this experience of what is such little money
for my mom and what answers the prayers for
someone else.
It’s this very confusing thing about the
world today, the inequality, the indignity
of poverty.
And I know all of us have probably had an
experience very personal with it.
And for me, I think, from that time, kind
of fast forward 15 years later I was in college
and I wanted to do something in India, I didn’t
know what it was and I was an economics major
at Stanford and I put together this slide
and I just wanna show it to you guys cause
I feel like a lot of us are in different places
of our journey.
One of the most common questions I get is,
“How did you end up at Kiva?” and, so, I
wanted to show this thing because this really,
I think, shows the kind of up and down path.
So, on a graph here, I charted my kind of
level of aliveness over time starting at the
age of 20 to basically today.
So, it started with sophomore slump and I
discovered microfinance in a class.
And what I loved about microfinance was it
was a business approach to poverty alleviation
and I’m a huge believer in the markets.
I just don’t think the markets always work
for the poor.
So, when I heard about what Muhammad Yunus
had done and this, kind of, incredible invention
called microfinance, I tried to direct all
my studies towards that.
And I was lucky enough to get a research grant
from the university to go and study at the
Self Employed Women’s Association which is
a large microfinance institution in Ahmedabad,
India and its seven hundred thousand members
and they do incredible work.
And then, like a lot of people are graduating
in '98, I became a management consultant in
New York.
>>Gary Briggs: I don’t know anyone who would
put management consultant at the top.
>>Premal Shah: Yeah, yeah.
[Laughter]
>>Premal Shah: Exactly.
It was completely
>>Gary Briggs: I was, like, on the same chart
at one point.
>>Premal Shah: The only validating thing about
being a management consultant is you can create
killer charts like this, I feel like.
[Laughter]
>>Premal Shah: But, you know, I don’t wanna
bag on it too much but it wasn’t for me.
And luckily, and I’m sure a lot of you guys
are here for the same reason, I was lucky
enough to join a company that was doing incredible
things with technology.
So I was an early employee over at PayPal.
And you know how fun it is to build things
that millions and millions of people use and
really value.
And you guys feel this every day and it’s
the most incredible company out there here
at Google.
And, so, it was so fun and so enjoyable and
I learned so much about the revolutionary
power of technology, to connect people, to
create opportunity.
And we were acquired by eBay but at some point
I experienced burn out and I really wanna
put this out there cause I don’t know where
everyone is at with their journey but, certainly,
I hit it.
And for me it was that 3 month sabbatical
that Winnie was talking about that absolutely
changed my life when I went back to India.
And that’s where I was testing the idea of,
hey could you make a microloan to someone
over the internet?
And it was when I came back, that’s when
I ran into you, Gary, in the hallway and we
were trying to brainstorm names.
Gary and I didn’t actually work together
in the same group but I knew he was like a
consumer marketing genius and we had like
a list of a hundred names that we’re trying
to figure out what we should call this website
that allows you to make microloans to each
other.
>>Gary Briggs: You were telling me one of
the ones earlier when we were talking about
one of the ones you didn’t go with which
I thought was pretty funny.
>>Premal Shah: Yeah, the leading name that
we had was grassroots capital dot org
[Laughter]
>>Premal Shah: And I loved it cause it describes
what Kiva does.
But then a friend of mine said, “Oh yea,
grassroots capital?
Yeah, legalize it.”
[Laughter]
>>Premal Shah: And so then I could never get
that image of smoking grassroots capital out
of my head.
So it killed that name.
[Laughter]
>>Gary Briggs: You would have had the logo
like that.
>>Premal Shah: Yes.
Exactly, exactly.
[Laughter]
>>Gary Briggs: So, on this chart which is
quite good by the way
[Laughter]
>>Premal Shah: Thanks.
>>Gary Briggs: Very well done.
Yeah.
Oh my God it’s working, so the early days
if you kind of go through it, it’s not all
up and to the right, I mean, people write
about those stories, it’s never up and to
the right, right away but also when you started
to see it was working, what started happening
in the early, early days?
>>Premal Shah: Yeah, so I remember I left
PayPal and Matt Flannery, the co-founder of
Kiva, left his job at TiVo, he was in computer
programming and he jokes about he’s pausing
live TV and getting really good at that and
he had an experience in Uganda that transformed
his life.
And, so, we’re, we both quit our jobs, we’re
both volunteering trying to kind of nurture
Kiva and I remember when he typed in Kiva
into Google, the top result was a spa in Santa
Cruz.
Like, it was completely, we used Google Analytics
really early on and maybe only a hundred people
would be coming to the website, probably looking
for the spa.
Only 2 or 3 would actually make a loan on
the website.
So, it wasn’t looking very good, in fact,
I looked in the database early on to see if
my parents had used the website.
[Laughter]
>>Premal Shah: And even they hadn’t used
it.
They were so pissed that I left like a good
career job at PayPal
[Laughter]
>>Premal Shah: for like a non-profit and they
were pissed I wasn’t a doctor, actually.
>>Gary Briggs: Hopefully they hadn’t told
you that they had used it.
[Laughter]
>>Gary Briggs: And then you checked the data
and they hadn’t.
>>Premal Shah: Yeah, exactly, exactly.
So when you get something started it’s really
hard to get the traction.
And the moment that kind of changed everything
was about a year into our existence.
We were volunteers for about 7 months and
then we knew we had to start putting people
on to healthcare and at least paying some
kind of living wage.
So about a year into our existence we had
about a month left of kind of cash in the
bank, it was about 5 people and, uh, and in
October 2006 absolutely changed the course
of Kiva which was, in that month, Muhammad
Yunus won the Nobel Peace Prize for his pioneering
work in microfinance, he’s the founder of
the Grameen Bank, they reach over 6 million
families in Bangladesh with loans and savings
and insurance and a variety of services.
Just an incredible, he’s a saint and he’s
walking on the planet today.
And then two weeks later we were on PBS Frontline
World which is this 15 minute documentary
that they created about Kiva and it was on
Halloween night, we’re sitting there, I remember
we’re looking at Google Analytics, we’re
gonna watch the traffic, you know, try to
go up, and we’re sitting there in our Halloween
costumes
[Laughter]
>>Premal Shah: And it hits on the East Coast
and all the sudden the traffic goes down to
0 and what happens is our site crashed
[Laughter]
>>Premal Shah: Cause we were on this 22 dollar
a month server plan, you know?
[Laughter]
>>Premal Shah: And it was so painful for the
next 4 days our site couldn’t get back up.
But, of course, on the internet when your
site crashes it actually builds the meme.
>>Gary Briggs: Yeah.
>>Premal Shah: So that, right there, more
than anything and, in fact, one of our engineers,
he basically put up a little PayPal button
that said, “You’ve melted our servers, help
us buy new ones.”
[Laughter]
>>Gary Briggs: Wow.
>>Premal Shah: Yeah, we raised 130,000 dollars
from the internet community
[Gasps]
>>Premal Shah: And that’s what allowed us
to get everyone on healthcare, actually do
real due diligence on these organizations
[Laughter]
>>Premal Shah: around the planet and get off
the 22 dollar a month server plan
[Laughter]
>>Premal Shah: So that was that moment in
time that then, from that point, you know,
um, things really started taking off
>>Gary Briggs: Yeah
>>Premal Shah: and people, the word started
spreading.
>>Gary Briggs: Yeah.
I have to admit I was imaging you four days
in your Halloween costume, running around
trying to make the server work.
[Laughter]
>>Premal Shah: I was in a penguin costume
and
>>Gary Briggs: A penguin costume?
That’s pretty good.
>>Premal Shah: And it was pretty ridiculous.
[Laughter]
>>Gary Briggs: So we should, I don’t know
how many, if everyone knows exactly how Kiva
works and you mentioned about Grameen and
a little bit of microfinance.
How does it work, how do you even get started?
>>Premal Shah: Sure, just by show of hands
how many of you folks have made a loan on
Kiva?
Awesome!
>>Gary Briggs: Wow.
>>Premal Shah: How many of you actually have
money sitting in your Kiva accounts that you
have to respend or relend to someone?
Okay, there’s about 25 million dollars sitting
in people’s Kiva accounts that could be in
the hands of the working poor.
So, just keep coming back and relending that
money.
And we’ve just built an auto loan feature
that allows you to automatically deploy it.
But I wanna walk through the user experience
of the website for those of you who haven’t
used it.
So, essentially, you come to the website and
you can go to our lend tab and, essentially,
we feature some loans across the top, like,
group loans, um, that typically go to poorer
microfinance clients.
Right now we’re featuring Arab youth loans,
they tend to be slower to fund sometimes on
our website.
We find that women fund faster than men.
Anyway, you can sift through, and, the site
and, I don’t know, let’s pick Télé in
Togo who wants a thousand dollars to purchase
beverages.
And, so basically what you can do is read
a little bit about Télé.
She’s posted by a Kiva field partner, and
this is what we do, Kiva is a non-profit organization
based in San Francisco.
We have about 90 staff members around the
world and a big part of what we do is we go
and find organizations like WAGES, here, and
we basically look at their social performance,
their work in the community and we give them
some kind of public badging and then we assign
them a risk rating.
So 1 to 5 star risk rating, if you’re a 5
star organization you can raise over a million
dollars from the internet community on the
platform, if you’re one star we start you
off at 25,000 dollars.
So it’s a way of basically allowing these
organizations, we’re giving them visibility
and voice to basically raise money so they
can reach more entrepreneurs in their community.
So they’re the real heroes at Kiva.
They’re the ones who are doing the hard work
every single day on the ground in over 60
countries.
So they’ve been on the Kiva platform for
50 months and they’ve posted up nearly four
thousand entrepreneurs onto the website.
Anyways, oh, and we use Google Maps right
here and you can kind of see where people
from around the world have lent to this borrower.
So, anyways, the way it works is, it’s pretty
simple, you can lend 25 dollars or more and
if you hit lend 25 one of the big questions
that we often get is, “How does Kiva pay
for the rent and for salaries?” About 60
percent of how we make our money is through
tips.
So, like, when you go to a restaurant you
tip a waiter an extra 15 percent, we ask you
to kind of throw in an extra 15 percent on
top of your 25 dollar loan.
And, on average, you know, we get about 7
percent, so about half the people stiff us.
But, you know, it’s those tips as well as
kind of donations from foundations, corporations
and individuals that allow us to kind of expand
into some of the hardest to reach places on
the planet.
And then a cool thing about Kiva is that it’s
a loan not a donation.
And usually every month, so the average loan
term on Kiva is about 10 months and you get
paid back in monthly installments.
So, if you lend 25 dollars you’ll get 2 dollars
and 50 cents emailed back to you every month
and that lands in your account as Kiva credit
and then once you get 25 dollars back you
can turn around and withdraw that money or
you can relend it.
Most people choose to relend their money to
another entrepreneur.
So that’s the basics of the Kiva user experience
and then, you know, often times you’ll get
an update on how the entrepreneur’s business
is doing.
And it’s not always good news, sometimes
businesses fail.
But it’s, what we wanna do is try to just
make, give a window into the world and make
it as accessible and easy as possible.
People participate as a business partners
not necessarily as a, you know, I’m your
benefactor and you’re my beneficiary but
really a partnership relationship.
>>Gary Briggs: Talk a little bit about, Winnie
had mentioned at the beginning throughput
for the week but just give a sense of scale
and how many folks are you reaching now?
>>Premal Shah: Sure, so Kiva today has reached
800,000 small businesses, entrepreneurs, students
in 62 countries, um, the total amount that
has flowed through the website is about 320
million dollars in 25 dollar increments from
about 800,000 people on the internet.
So there’s incredible symmetry between the
number of people who are lending on the website
and the number of people who are borrowing.
That’s a really cool thing.
80 percent of the loans go to women
>>Gary Briggs: Yeah.
That’s what you said before.
It’s more women than men.
>>Premal Shah: Yeah, it’s more women than
men and there’s a 98.9 repayment rate on
the website.
>>Gary Briggs: Wow, much better than mortgages
in California.
[Laughter]
>>Premal Shah: Yeah, yeah it’s, we did a
graph between, I think, the S and P 500 over
the last 5 years and kind of did a Kiva portfolio
and the working poor are outperforming.
>>Gary Briggs: Some other folks.
>>Premal Shah: Some other classes, yeah.
>>Gary Briggs: So you mentioned when you asked
the group about how many folks had accounts
with balances and that you had the auto donate
feature, talk a little about some of the features,
cause you and I were talking about this the
other day that there are some new features
you have on the site.
>>Premal Shah: Yeah, so just to, just to show
a few features on the website.
One that I’m really excited about is the
community tab, right, so this, what we realize
is that people doing social good can be a
social experiment or social experience.
One of the things that we kind of built without
really thinking too much about is the ability
to create your own lending team, for example,
the Atheists and the Christians are the top
2 lending teams at Kiva
[Laughter]
>>Premal Shah: And they compete with each
other, it’s incredible.
The third team is the Milepoints team.
These are people that wanna get credit card
points
[Laughter]
>>Premal Shah: by lending on Kiva and getting
the money back.
And then there’s team Europe
[Laughter]
>>Premal Shah: And then the Friends Bob Harris,
this guy, he’s beating the Australians.
[Laughter]
>>Premal Shah: So it’s really amazing.
There’s 22,000 teams, there’s over a thousand
schools, 1,300 universities, there’s, I think,
a Google team.
Let’s see.
[Laughter]
>>Premal Shah: It’s the moment of truth here.
>>Gary Briggs: Apparently we’re not beating
Bob Harris.
>>Premal Shah: Yeah we only have 58 members
of the Google team here.
[Laughter]
>>Premal Shah: But you guys are, yeah, I mean,
it’s 40,000 dollars lent.
A lot of Googlers using the website aren’t
even aware of the Google team.
>>Gary Briggs: Yeah.
>>Premal Shah: Consider joining it cause it’s
a, kind of, track your progress together as
a community.
The other thing that Gary, you know, that
you pointed out is the auto lending feature.
Which is basically, I won’t demo it, but
in your “my portfolio” page you can kind
of set a few perimeters, women, women in Uganda,
um, who are in agriculture and then anytime
a woman from Uganda in agriculture comes on
the website it will automatically deploy that
money.
>>Gary Briggs: Great.
Any, any, um, you kind of think about some
of the, well one of the things that’s amazing
is the stories that come out from the users
but there’s some incredible even somewhat
bizarre in some cases, I guess.
But interesting stories of folks and who you’re
reaching.
>>Premal Shah: Yeah, you know, there’s so
many amazing stories throughout the year and,
I mean, I just love reading through the site
every day.
And I think, when you make a loan to someone
you get to participate in their journey as
a business owner.
And there’s so many creative ways that people
create a living for themselves.
So, one of the things I’m really excited
about is kind of some of the new ways that
our field partners are really trying to help
the under-served.
If this room right now were the country of
Kenya, everyone from right here to here would
be rural subsistence farmers.
One of the challenges is reaching you with
microfinance.
It’s so far, I mean, if, just imagine the
most rural place you’ve been to.
It’s very, very hard and costly to get to
you.
But then, you know, one of the organizations
that I think is just amazing, we’re working
with this organization called Juhudi Kilimo
and, in fact, a Google employee helped develop
a management information system for this organization,
it’s a really progressive org.
But what they do is they provide a hybrid
cow to farmers.
And a hybrid cow, what’s a hybrid cow?
Well, typically cows in that area deliver
milk once a day; these cows deliver milk twice
a day.
And often times, it’s called asset-based
financing.
So when you lend to a Juhudi Kilimo borrower
on Kiva, instead of the borrower getting money
they’ll get a cow and usually it’s a two
for one where the cow is pregnant.
[Laughter]
>>Premal Shah: So, it’s amazing and you’re
literally right there doubling the farmer’s
dairy income, right?
And it’s an incredible intervention and they
offer an insurance service and, I mean, these
are things that are happening all around the
planet right now.
I mean, another thing
>>Gary Briggs: You can't go on next, how does
that work with a hybrid cow?
[Laughter]
>>Premal Shah: More fuel efficient
>>Premal Shah: So basically it’s mixed with
a European strain that is just a higher producing
cow in terms of milk.
>>Gary Briggs: Wow.
>>Premal Shah: But since it also has, I guess,
a local strain it’s more, I guess
>>Gary Briggs: Resilient.
>>Premal Shah: Yeah, resilient.
So there’s these interventions all around
the planet that make so much sense.
I mean, we see things with solar power cookers
that can save you, the avoided cost from having
to go and gather wood, to heat and light your
home,
>>Gary Briggs: The fumes
>>Premal Shah: The fumes
>>Gary Briggs: are terrible, yeah.
>>Premal Shah: The fumes from kerosene kill
more people every year in the developing world
than malaria.
>>Gary Briggs: Yeah.
>>Premal Shah: Respiratory illnesses.
And one in three people live in energy poverty
are completely off the grid.
So there’s real cost, you actually, it’s
a poverty penalty when you’re poor.
You pay more for the basic services that the
middle class and rich have access to.
>>Gary Briggs: The time it takes to go get
water or the time it takes to or the danger
you run into trying to go get wood, it is
pretty extraordinary.
>>Premal Shah: Exactly.
So if you can get patient capital to finance
basically a technology like a solar power
cooker or being able to create a main line
to the direct water source, your avoided cost
over time would be, you’d be able to make
those monthly payments back.
>>Gary Briggs: Yeah.
>>Premal Shah: It’s, I think the clearest
example here in the U.S. is if the government
said any vehicle that has over 50 miles per
gallon gets zero percent interest financing
for 30 years, it’s like mortgages are 30
years long, so your monthly payments are so
low that it’s a no brainer from your fuels
cost savings to actually go and switch over.
More American households would buy Priuses,
etcetera.
And so I think that’s the idea here.
Beyond just starting small businesses there’s
a lot of costs that people pay that if they
could, in exchange for small monthly payments,
a large lump sum they could buy technology
that could change their life.
>>Gary Briggs: Yeah, and get back to, yeah,
that’s totally, and the time it benefits
too.
I mean, so we were talking a little about
it at the beginning and the idea of up and
to the right, you guys are still a small business,
still out trying to do what you can.
What are some of the challenges you’re currently
facing in running the company?
>>Premal Shah: Well, I think, um, the two
biggest challenges, one is, you know, for
anyone that’s read about microfinance in
the last couple years, it’s not perfect.
It’s not a silver bullet.
There’s a lot of issues and it’s a very
young, it’s a promising developing intervention
but it has its limitations.
And one of the things that affects me the
most is, we were just talking about Kenya,
if you live in a rural area the cost of getting
you these loans especially if it’s a hundred
dollars, for this organization to be able
to basically go out on its moped, you know,
two hours into the village and make a hundred
dollar loan disbursement and then every week
come back in a group meeting and collect a
little bit each time over the next 50 weeks,
it’s very costly if you look at the interest
rates.
And, so, one of the things, you know, I really
struggle with is how do you continue to make
the costs go down for the world’s working
poor?
It’s not risk based pricing because most
of, we have 98 percent rate
>>Gary Briggs: Higher repayment rates
>>Premal Shah: Yeah we have great repayment
rates.
It’s, I think, it’s, it’s around how do
we use technologies to make the credit appraisal
as well as the disbursement and collection
of cash, how do we address that?
So that’s one big challenge.
The second big challenge is, you know, while
microfinance today has reached about a 150
million people, so it’s pretty successful
in a scale, there’s about 2.5 billion people
who are left out of the system today.
And if we go on the Kiva website, when I was
showing that kind of lend tab, you see business
that were expiring.
These are people who in this hour need a few
hundred bucks and they’ll go unfunded on
the website.
And that’s just a reflection of high impact
but underfunded things that are happening
all over the planet.
This is just a window into that.
And so what I wanna do, now Kiva in the beginning
we kept running out of loans.
Like every Christmas, you’d log into Kiva
and we’d be out of loans on the website cause
it’s very challenging in low bandwidth environments
to actually get these loans posted.
Now we have too many loans.
>>Gary Briggs: Yeah.
>>Premal Shah: And not enough people coming.
So if you’re ever thinking about trying Kiva,
this is a big reason why I’m here at Google
today, I’ve never done a talk in 6 years,
I think now’s the time to really get out
the word and really spread it.
Then what we do is we send a signal to the
NGOs all around the planet that, you know
what, the internet community it’s, there’s,
it’s a real source of patient capital.
>>Gary Briggs: Yeah.
>>Premal Shah: And, so, those are kind of
the two big challenges right now.
>>Gary Briggs: Just cause, we talk a little
bit about this too, but digging into that,
and you mentioned about 80 percent of the
loans were to women, 20 percent were to men.
Are there particular loan types that are more
likely to close than others?
Do you see patterns?
>>Premal Shah: What we see if women fund two
times faster than men on the website.
The agriculture sector, if you’re, that’s
the fastest to funds sector, transportation
is the slowest.
You know, we see, for example, surprisingly,
for example, loans in Iraq were originally
very popular and now we’ve seen those expire
more and more.
I wonder if it’s because it’s out of our
consciousness.
So we’re starting to see these patterns and
what we wanna do is just continue to layer
on more and more pieces of information so
people can make decisions not only with their
heart but also with their head and then just
get the word out.
>>Gary Briggs: So you mentioned at the very
beginning of things like Frontline, you can’t
have a Frontline documentary every day, but
in terms of getting the word out, it is really
hard.
I mean are there certain tactics that you’ve
found that have been more helpful than others?
Is it, you know, PR?
Is it AdWords?
Is it, you know, other people telling other
people?
What works best for you in terms of growing
demand cause, as you mentioned, you’ve got
a good supply now?
>>Premal Shah: Yeah, you know, one thing we’ve
done that was pretty interesting is Reid Hoffman,
who is the founder of LinkedIn and he’s made
a lot of money recently and
[Laughter]
>>Premal Shah: And we both worked with him
at PayPal and
>>Gary Briggs: I see him on TV all the time
now
[Laughter]
>>Gary Briggs: He’s got a book.
>>Premal Shah: Yeah, he’s on Bloomberg, he’s
got his own thing, yeah.
He’s awesome.
[Laughter]
>>Premal Shah: He's awesome.
So what he’s done is he’s like, “Look,
I’m not gonna go and lend 25 dollars to people.”
He put out a million dollars to the internet
community and we converted that into 40 thousand
free 25 dollar trials.
And then we put that out on twitter and said,
“Use Kiva for free.” And it’s even on the
header of our website right now.
Usually every month, ten thousand people will
try Kiva with their own money, well, in the
month of March 40 thousand new people tried
Kiva for free.
And here’s the genius of this program, when
someone tries that 25 dollar loan of Reid’s
money, they’ll lend it to somebody in Cambodia
and as that woman in Cambodia repays her loan
the money goes back to Reid.
So Reid’s real cost is the default rate on
Kiva.
So, although he’s gen, you know, mobilized
a million dollars and 40 thousand new people,
his real cost will only be able 10 thousand
or 11 thousand dollars.
Already 12 percent have put in their own money
and will probably recycle it over and over
and over.
So, those are some things, but I think it’s
just an all out effort at building awareness
about any cause.
What we’re trying to do is actually create
a single brand and then behind what’s happening
is there’s many NGOs and they’re working
in many different communities.
And instead of having them spend money building
their own brand, building their own technologies
to fund-raise, let’s make it as efficient
as possible for them and create a simple consumer
experience for people to connect with the
work that they’re doing around the planet.
>>Gary Briggs: Well, you mentioned as you
were telling stories about Kenya and M-Pesa
is a mobile technology, there’s a lot of
technologies that are now helping on distribution,
can you talk a little bit about what you’re
seeing, whether it be outbound or inbound?
>>Premal Shah: Yeah, I think the coolest thing
in terms of financial services for the poor;
the big game changer is mobile finance.
I’m sure many of you here have heard of M-Pesa.
M-Pesa is a mobile payments technology in
Kenya and what it allows you to do, Gary,
if I, I can kind of send you money stored
value to your phone, then you can go tell
local gas station and send the gas station
owner money and he will pull money out of
his till, Kenyan shillings and give it to
you.
So everyone almost kind of turns into an ATM
machine, if you will.
>>Gary Briggs: Yeah.
>>Premal Shah: And it’s about 4 years old.
78 percent of the adult population in Kenya
uses it, 25 percent of the GDP now flows through
this M-Pesa mobile payment system.
It’s incredibly promising, in fact, there’s
this quote by William Gibson, he talks about
the future’s here, it’s just not evenly
distributed yet.
[Laughter]
>>Premal Shah: And everyone talks about the
Silicon Valley and what’s happening out here
but I wonder why Kenya is so far ahead in
terms of mobile payments.
It’s incredible because what it does is people
who live in rural areas, the cost of actually
getting them a loan has completely collapsed.
And we’re doing a pilot now with Kiva where
instead of having a microfinance institution
in the middle, we’re actually doing something
where if you’ve gotten a loan on Kiva before,
or a church group can vouch for you, you can
get listed up in Kenya.
We have 80 borrowers in Kenya, it’s a pilot
called Kiva Zip.
And then when you lend money to that person,
within minutes the money goes to them at zero
percent interest.
And there incentive to repay is a future loan
that will be cheap.
Just like, this is why we pay back our credit
cards, cause we don’t wanna ruin our credit
score so that we can actually get future access
to opportunities.
So, the M-Pesa system, you know, we think
combined with crowd funding, can really collapse
the cost.
The cost, for example, accepting savings,
savings is really expensive for banks to offer
to the poor because you can’t charge an interest
rate, you actually have to pay out a little
bit on the deposits, but now people are saving
money on their cell phones.
And there’s this great quote from this woman
that I heard on Kiva in Kenya that said, “My
husband may try to break into my phone but
he’ll never be able to get the money off
my sim.”
[Laughter]
>>Premal Shah: So what it does in terms of
women’s agency, people's agency
>>Gary Briggs: Probably why men should get
loans
>>Premal Shah: Well, you know, it’s a game
changer.
It’s allowing people to have the security,
the privacy, the convenience of mobile finance.
I think that’s something we’re really excited
about.
>>Gary Briggs: And the distribution, I mean,
obviously the distribution power is extraordinary.
I had a chance in Kenya, I was with the tribesmen,
this was about 3 years back, and I was trying
to take a photo of him and he had a robe and
he kept covering, he had a Kipling case holder,
I remember, and his cell phone.
This was in the middle of nowhere and I’m
trying to take a picture of him and he’s
trying to cover it up cause he didn’t want
any photo of him with a cell phone.
But the distribution of these and ability
to move money on them is could be very transformative
for what you guys are trying to do.
So we have a lot of, it’s great we have a
really great turn out but folks, in a couple
more minutes we’ll ask you guys for questions.
But, what can Googlers do to help you guys?
>>Premal Shah: Sure.
Well, just your existence is awesome and I
wanna honor that, honestly.
[Laughter]
>>Gary Briggs: I think we mostly agree with
that.
[Laughter]
>>Premal Shah: No, I mean I say this from
a place of, we were counting up, the other
day, the number of services we use from Google
and, you know, uh, you know, from Google Apps
to using the maps on every single borrower
page to, we’re really trying to drive more
video on the website cause that seems to resonate
with the internet community.
So we’re working with Hunter Walk and his
team at YouTube.
To, I mean, it’s just, it’s ridiculous and
you hear this, I’m sure, from all sorts of
website owners but I just wanna thank you
guys for, and you guys do it at a price and
a quality that really enables NGOs around
the planet to be more effective.
So that’s really, I just wanna honor that.
Couple things, you know, obviously there’s
making a loan .You can get involved by volunteering
at Kiva.
We have a program called the Kiva Fellows
Program where you can go, we’ll train you
in San Francisco in our office for a week,
and then we’ll ship you out to 1 of 60 countries
where you can get an experience helping building
that local field partner and their work with
Kiva.
We’ve had over 450 Kiva Fellows now, in the
last few years, and a lot of Googlers have
done it.
I know you guys have peer bonuses and spot
bonuses here and you give out cash, well,
we have Kiva gift cards and it’s kind of
like cash because you can give someone 250
dollars, they will then just, the only condition
is they have to lend it out to someone and
then over the course of the year they’ll
get paid back and withdraw that cash.
So it’s simple things like that, just weaving
it into our day, that, and I think the person
might appreciate it just as much as cash.
Those are some of the ideas that we have and
if people are interested in doing something
like what Reid did, or just kind of doing
a bulk loan on a platform so that the internet
community, particularly I think classrooms
around the world, if we can let them try it
for free, I think that’s a really exciting
thing.
And I wanna make this as, it’s just, we know
when something’s, it’s the one penny problem,
if you can make it free more people will use
it and then over time people may put in their
own money.
So those are some ideas.
>>Gary Briggs: Okay.
That’s a good idea with a spot bonus you
get a Kiva
>>Premal Shah: Kiva gift card.
>>Gary Briggs: Kiva Care or something like
that.
>>Premal Shah: Yeah.
>>Gary Briggs: That’s a really great idea.
So, if there are questions what we’ll do
is you can just stand up or raise your hand
if you have a question and then hopefully
if we can hear it we’ll repeat it for folks
on VC.
Yes?
[Skips question]
>>Premal Shah: The profiles of the people
that you see here, typically, what happens
is the non-profit partner that we work with
or the NGO, will predispurse the money cause
we don’t want these people to wait for a
loan.
And then they backfill the loan, so while
they’re fundraising, the average loan profile
on Kiva gets funded in about 3 days.
But if it goes to day 30 and it’s not a hundred
percent funded, it expires off our website.
Now, when you make a loan to Luciana here
in the Philippines, if she defaults, so if
her business is not successful, then you and
the 20 other people who have chipped in to
fund her loan will lose your money.
So your repayment is tied to her success.
>>female #1: But in terms of, what happens
if she got the money but it didn’t get funded
by Kiva?
So who’s covering it?
>>Premal Shah: That’s where the local field
partner eats the loss and that’s the risk.
And then the more that happens, the less people
in their community that they reach.
And then you get your money back and hopefully
you’ll recycle it.
>>female #1: But suppose, okay, what about
the business, like I put in 25 dollars but
she hasn’t reached her 350 dollars and it’s
still counted towards what goes to her, I
mean, does that go immediately
>>Gary Briggs: I think the question is, is
it up to date?
>>female #1: Do you see what I’m saying?
>>Premal Shah: Yeah.
So what we do is we have an all or nothing
model which is once it hits its fundraising
target, then we wire on a monthly basis to
our field partners and so if it doesn’t hit
that 300 dollar threshold then that, none
of that money goes to that field partner.
It actually goes back to the internet lender
and it goes back to your Kiva account to put
it somewhere else.
>>Gary Brigg: It’s like a Groupon tip; the
loan has to tip over
>>female #1: If I put in 25 dollars and it’ll
sit there for 30 days and then I’ll get it
back?
>>Premal Shah: That’s
>>female #1: Does that make sense?
>>Premal Shah: Exactly.
And today that happens probably, it’s the
minority case but it’s happening at an increasing
rate.
>>Gary Briggs: Just cause you’re getting
more requests for loans.
>>Premal Shah: Yeah.
>>Gary Briggs: Okay, yes?
[Skips question]
>>Premal Shah: It’s important to keep in
mind, one of the best books I’ve read on
microfinance and financial services for the
poor is called Portfolios of the Poor and
the situation is much more complex than village
money-lender bad, Kiva good.
It’s actually, if you’re a poor household,
chances are you’ll have loans from multiple
sources; friends and family, your neighbors,
microfinance institution, some from a village
money-lender and what we love to do at Kiva
is make the internet community part of that
mix.
Cause we think the internet community will
be more patient and do it at a lower cost
than the village money-lender and even some
other formal sector things.
Um, so, my sense is that right now maybe some
of our, some microfinance institutions or
money-lenders would be upset about the internet
community doing it but I don’t know, I mean,
you guys deal with this all the time, there’s
existing ways of things and then technology
can create a new way and it can create more
value for people.
And, you know, we try not to get too bogged
down by that.
>>Gary Briggs: It’s not like being in Brooklyn,
they have to travel a long way to get to you
so you feel personally connected.
>>Premal Shah: That’s right.
>>Gary Briggs: Yes?
[skips question]
>>Premal Shah: I wanna show you guys something
that I think is one of the coolest things.
It just happened in the last few months.
We launched the ability for you, what’s your
name?
>>male #1: Alex.
>>Premal Shah: Alex, you can vouch for someone,
we’re gonna roll this out, it’s, right now
it’s a password protected limited pilot thing
that we’re running, you can vouch for someone
who you think is underserved, that is a small
business, say maybe in the Tenderloin in San
Francisco.
Okay, and this person, they might not have
a credit score that allows them to get a loan
from a bank but if you know their character
and are willing to vouch for them, for example,
we’re working with Glide Memorial Church
in San Francisco, if they know someone in
their congregation that they really wanna
back, they can vouch for them.
So I wanna show you what we’re doing now
within the US because people are more online,
right?
So, here is Victor.
Victor runs Cafeto Coffee Shop in San Francisco
California and this is his Kiva Zip experiment
that we’re running.
And he basically, you know, he got paid out
via PayPal, his interest rate is zero percent
and it’s a 12 months repayment term.
The people who vouched for him is the Mission
Economic Development Agency in the Mission
District in San Francisco.
Victor graduated from one of their business
training courses, wants to set up a coffee
shop and the internet community basically
has helped him raise his 5,000 dollars.
And now he’s running his coffee shop, he
employs 5 people part time and he’s paid
back 43 percent of the loan.
Now, here’s where it gets, I think, really
amazing as people, as the under-served, as
the working poor come more and more online,
Victor vouched for his friend Ernesto.
So, Ernesto is a taxi cab driver who wants
to buy a taxi cab medallion in San Francisco.
And you can see that now, Victor, has endorsed
Ernesto.
And Ernesto and Victor basically, here’s
the, you know, here’s the experiment we,
the hope is that Ernesto will really want
to pay back because Victor’s reputation is
tied to his repayment.
And this is a way that I think we can reach
people at a call structure that, you know,
it’s like trust networks, essentially.
So we’re really excited about this Kiva Zip
experiment.
I don’t know if this is gonna work but this
is, I think, we can test a lot of the edges
of innovation here in the U.S. because people
are more connected and it’s easier to reach
them and do these pilots and PayPal we can
get money to them.
And we’re also running this pilot in Kenya
because of M-Pesa as well.
>>Gary Briggs: There’s a question just behind
Alex.
Sorry, yeah?
[Skips question]
>>Gary Briggs: So I think it’s kind of an
incubator question.
Are you helping kind of incubator type activity,
yeah?
>>Premal Shah: You know that’s a really great
idea.
You can image that Victor and Ernesto, you
know, as there are more and more of folks
just here in the San Francisco Bay Area who
are using Kiva to make their case to internet
community to get loan funds, patient capital,
that we could layer in other value-add services.
So, for example, Google has a small business
unit and maybe you guys have training and
we could develop a module, it’s like a, it’s
a Kiva, Google boot camp for entrepreneurs
who want to now bring their business online.
And these two businesses might not be online
but I’m sure there are ones.
Or, for example, we can use the reputation
systems that you guys have developed.
You know the community feedback score on small
businesses?
As a way to actually get, get, raise money
on Kiva.
So, there’s so many things that we could
do, we’re really early in kind of thinking
through how to layer it in.
But I think there’s a lot of promise.
>>Gary Briggs: Is there a question over here,
I thought?
Yep, go ahead.
That’s great.
[Skips question]
>>Premal Shah: So I’m familiar with Wokai,
I’m good friends with Casey, there CEO and
co-founder.
And, you know, I think it speaks to the plight
of, it’s really hard, it’s, it’s, it’s
Kiva for China, that’s what Wokai is.
And they’ve been at it for a few years and
just in May they’ve had to close down and
it’s really hard to find funding and keep
going.
And unless you get that kind of flag wheel
effect or that traction, it’s really hard
to make this model work.
And, so, one of the things we wanna learn
from Wokai is actually take a lot of the learning’s
in China and figure out how we can actually
lever this platform, all of this goodwill,
that’s been built to get into China more
efficiently so that for every dollar spent
running Kiva, we can have even more levered
impact.
And, so, this is the case for actually, non-profits
actually coming together and consolidating
more and sometimes failure can be good.
There’s that Darwinism cause that way we
can kind of focus our resources and get the
most impact.
>>Gary Briggs: Yeah, that’s great.
Was there a question in the front row?
No, did you have a question?
>>female #1: Oh, I had one other one
>>Gary Briggs: You did?
Okay, over by the wall.
Yes, please.
>>Premal Shah: So just to summarize your question,
a few things, one is around interest rates,
two is just around how this money is spent?
Loan capital spent?
Is it consumptive or is it for productive
purposes?
Those, uh, it was in that set
>>female #1: [inaudible]
>>Premal Shah: Sure.
Here’s what, I mean, what you guys do at
Google, you guys are gonna be a part of this
overall solution where the world’s going.
Which is as we get more insight into small
businesses, so as you get cash register data,
one of the loan types we’re doing now on
Kiva is, for example, if we, if there’s,
if this guy has, I guess, Google Wallet or
a square device to accept the credit cards,
that data could then basically show up to
Kiva lenders, right?
And what we could do is structure a loan so
that a percentage of revenues actually up
to a zero percent return, or maybe one day
if the SEC allowed it you could even get for
profit returns, who knows.
But that kind of data insight could actually
get us a better sense between people who invest
and how that money, you know, how that money
is used and, and the income generation.
The truth though, is, for the working poor,
these loans often times are subsistence loans
and the more valuable thing about the loan
is the ability to cope with a crisis whether
it’s a medical emergency, a funeral expense,
kids going to school, yes it’s consumptive
but it comes into a mix in a household in
a bulk sum in exchange for small affordable
repayments over a longer period of time.
One thing that we screen for at Kiva is over
indebtedness.
It happened here in the U.S. with the subprime
meltdown which is, often times people, you
know credit can be debt and it can really
work against you if you don’t know portion
control or if it’s not done in a fair, transparent
way.
And I think there are some cases, for example,
in Southern India by some for-profit microfinance
organizations, which I’m a huge fan of for
profit, I want the poor to be able to take
advantage of profitable services but sometimes
that motive for growth, growth, growth comes
at the expense of responsibility.
And, so, we have to be very mindful about
how to be responsible lenders and there’s
things around price transparency, fair collection
practices and I think the industry, especially
in Southern India, there’s a pretty stark
reminder of when microfinance can actually
harm and not help.
So we wanna screen out for the right organizations
that have a much more balanced view on growth.
That’s our perspective at Kiva.
>>Gary Briggs: So there’s probably time for
two more questions so just go over to the
wall.
[Skips question]
>>Premal Shah: Yeah, the question was about
fraud.
[Laughter]
>>Premal Shah: And fraud absolutely happens,
all the time.
And one of the things that
>>Gary Briggs: One of the things we used to
say at PayPal is you know you’re successful
when the fraudsters come after you.
It’s the way
[Laughter]
>>Premal Shah: That’s good stuff.
>>Gary Briggs: It’s true.
It’s the nature of money on the web, unfortunately.
>>Premal Shah: Yeah, early on, too, when we
didn’t have very good due diligence practices
we were defrauded all the time.
[Laughter]
>>Premal Shah: And now we’re still defrauded
but less so as the percentage of the loan
volume.
In fact, I think the first 10 field partners
we signed up, I think 8 of them we’ve had
to close down because of malfeasance or they,
we just didn’t know what we were doing.
And, you know, I think the thing, we know
fraud and corruption is a fact of life, this
is the way this state of the world I, what
we wanna do is just put a little sunlight
on it.
So by having internet platforms you can go
through our field partner page and see the
30 partners that we’ve had to close out of
the 200 because of problems and you can read
why.
And hopefully a future donor or a future funder
won’t come in, they’ll Google the partner
name in Cambodia or in the U.S. or wherever
and they’ll say, “Oh, looks like they had
some problems on Kiva.
What happened?” They can read about it and
we even invite the organization to state their
case and we just wanna put more sunlight on
all of this and that way people don’t throw
good money after bad.
>>Gary Briggs: People who defraud Kiva have
a special place in the afterlife I would think.
[Laughter]
>>Premal Shah: You know, it teaches us and
even with the Zip model, we found in intermediary
they’ll still be, you know, Victor and Ernesto
could collude, right?
>>Gary Briggs: Yeah.
>>Premal Shah: I mean we haven’t seen that
yet it’s still a really small pilot so it’s
just human nature, there’s always some bad.
The question is can we minimize the bad so
we can allow all this good to flourish?
>>Gary Briggs: I love the fact that you do
keep it up there and you kind of shine a light
on it that’s actually a great practice.
Last question.
[Skips question]
>>Premal Shah: Well, I’m a big believer in
doing the smallest possible thing in the present
moment and try smallify things, I mean, if,
think, what Kiva does so well is we all know
the world’s problems and I think there’s
compassion collapse.
You start hearing these stats, one trillion
this, one billion that and we just wanna make
this human scale and make this something that
people can do very quickly, very simply, with
a low barrier to entry.
And then I think it’s just, how we move that
practice, that mindfulness, into what we’re
doing every day.
And that, you know, I, hopefully that answers
your question beyond kind of like making a
loan is, you know, I don’t know, take a breath.
Be grateful for the place and time that we
are in right here, I mean, what a joy to,
especially to work for a company that, I mean,
you know, I really believe in what you guys
are doing and you guys spend a lot of time
and resources on things that don’t seem to
have an immediate economic return for the
company and I really, I think you guys walk
your talk.
So, oh, around do no evil and, I really believe
that.
I see that for the last 10 years or whatever.
So, I’d just savor the time that you have
here.
And then, you know, more than social entrepreneurs,
people quit the company and go leave and start
something, social intrepreneurs.
The amount of change you can make with the
resources here at Google, banding people together,
I mean, we wanna create, for example, some
kind of, I was talking to our lead engineer
last night, I was like, “What would be helpful
for Google engineers to do?” and he was like,
“Well, we could use help” if you guys had
a sabbatical program here, we’re right here
in San Francisco creating, it’s called an
open source playground because the list of
ideas is so long but our ability to get them
done is just, you know, it’s very slow.
And, so, if we could open up the ability for
all developers to come in and develop things
and through some kind of stage gate path put
it up onto the website that would really unlock
the potential of this.
And this is only one of the websites, all
these other systems, like the systems that
are, our field partners use around the world,
I mean, they all need a lot of engineering,
love and attention , for example.
So, get involved with local non-profits that
do global things or things in your own neighborhood,
too.
>>Gary Briggs: Sounds like we need a hack-a-thon
at Kiva.
[Laughter]
>>Premal Shah: Yeah, we should do a hack-a-thon,
that’s for sure.
>>Gary Briggs: Alright, I think we’re about
out of time.
Premal it’s great, I mean, it’s a great
audience in terms of turn out and things like
that.
You’ve been incredible from the time I met
you in the hallway.
So keep going at it.
It’s having a huge impact in the world, so
thank you.
>>Premal Shah: Cool, thanks.
[Applause]